um so definitely in MMA Samoa guys are
doing a lot better than Jitsu guys are
that's because some of my guys have far
better wrestling and they have better
submission wrestling than Jiu Jitsu guys
and it all depends on what context
you're talking about if you put a
Ensemble guy in 80cc for example they do
notoriously bad but if you see them in
MMA they're doing pretty well there you
know I think that it depends on the
contacts you're talking about but I
think for definitely for grappling you
know our Olympics is ADCC if you look at
guys competing in ADCC they do
notoriously bad compare their Jitsu guys
so that's why I I give the edge at least
in grappling to to jujitsu